dans ce restaurant de dole la brigade
semble déjà sur son 31
d'ailleurs voici à quoi ressemblera
l'une des entrées du menu de la saint
sylvestre un repas que l'on a d'ailleurs
tendance à réserver de plus en plus au
dernier moment un menu et une soirée qui
ont évolué en quelque sorte au fil du
temps on est dans un esprit beaucoup
plus cocooning on veut on veut vraiment
partagé un moment gastronomique et en
effet on n'est plus sûr de deux quatre
six personnes on dirait presque une
saint-valentin bis
en effet on veut rationaliser nos
budgets et les budgets de nos clients ce
que recherchent vraiment le client et on
le sait c'est le rapport qualité prix et
on y met toutes nos efforts dans cette 2
dans ce domaine la plupart des
restaurants ouverts le 31 affiche des
menus spéciaux plutôt haut de gamme avec
des tarifs autour de 70 80 euros par
personne sans les boissons dans le vieux
dole ce restaurateur propose lui aussi
un réveillon gastronomique est assez
intimiste j'ai un petit restaurant 40
couverts et j'ai pas de la place pour
faire la musique je prenne la place pour
faire de l'ambiance
une soirée dansante les gens recherchent
pas forcément ça en venant ici n'ont pas
forcément pour faire dans un restaurant
a pris ils seraient joints pour faire ça
ailleurs
voilà entre copains voilà mais là encore
on est très attentif au prix demandé
aujourd'hui tout le monde content et on
en est très conscient donc on essaie
d'allier les saveurs et le bonheur et et
que tout ça ça fasse un quelque chose de
sympa célébrer le nouvel an dans une
bonne table de la région a donc toujours
autant de succès mais il ya aussi de
plus en plus de demandes pour
réveillonner le 24 décembre au
restaurant une date où les
établissements sont généralement fermés